Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Anyone who has tried building bridges
over a huge chasm realized that it is
possibly one of the most difficult *and*
dangerous things you could do on a
family vacation. The basic construction
elements for such a bridge can be ropes,
cables, and wires. And this kind of task
is fundamentally different from
classical architectural building
problems. Here, you don't need to have any
kind of scaffolding or to carry building
blocks that weigh a lot.
However, you have to know how to tie
knots therefore this is the kind of
problem you'll need flying machines for.
They can fly anywhere. They are nimble.
And their disadvantage that they have a
very limited payload does not play a big
role here. In this piece of work at the
ETH Zürich these machines can create some
crazy knots: from single to multi-round-turn hitches,
knobs, elbows, round turns
and multiple rope knobs. And these you
have to be able to create in a
collaborative manner because each
individual flying machine will hold one rope,
therefore they have to pass through
given control points at the strictly
given time and a target velocity.
These little guys also have to know the exact
amount of force they need to exert on
the structure to move into a desirable
target position. Even deploying the rope
is not that trivial. The machine is
equipped with a roller to do so, but the
friction of this roller can be changed
at any time according to the rope
releasing direction to unroll it properly.
You also have to face the correct
direction as well. And these structures
are not just toys.
The resulting bridges are resilient
enough for humans to use. This work is a
great example to show that the
technology of today is improving at an
incredible pace. If we can solve
difficult collaborative control problems
such as this one just think about the possibilities..
What an exciting time it is to be alive!
We have gotten lots of shares for the
series on social media. I'm trying to
send a short
thank you message for every single one
of you. I'm trying my best and don't
forget: every single share helps spreading
the word for the series immensely.
Thanks for watching and I'll see you next time!